In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 26 on which we commemorate the Holy Virgin
martyr, Paraskevi of Rome.
The Holy and Great Marjorie Paraskevi was born during Hadrian's reign in the years 117-138
in a village near Rome, the daughter of Agathon and Politea, Christian parents, who for many
years had asked the Lord for a child.
God, who always fulfills the desires of those who fear Him, gave them a daughter whom they
named Paraskevi, both because she was born on a Friday and from devotion to the life-giving
passion of our Lord Jesus Christ.
From earliest childhood, she consecrated herself entirely to the things of God, feeling
no attraction for childish games.
She spent all her time either in church being present at the offices or at home, praying
or meditating on the Word of God.
She was 12 years old when her parents died, and she distributed their great wealth to those
in need, and took the veil, a sign of her consecration to God, after passing some time
in complete submission to her abyss, being desirous of sharing the treasure of the faith
with others.
She left the monastery, and went through towns and villages proclaiming the name of Christ.
Through her proclamation, she brought many pagans to the true faith, and aroused the hatred
and jealousy of the Jews, who denounced her to the ruler of the region in which she found
herself.
He immediately ordered the arrest of this noble Christian, and had her brought before him.
When he saw her, he was overcome by her beauty, and quickly tried to win her over through
flattery, saying, If you let yourself be convinced by my words, and agree to offer sacrifice,
you will receive great wealth.
But if you persist in your stubborn refusal, know that I shall hand you over to terrible
tortures.
The frail young girl replied to him with a virile boldness.
I shall never deny my most sweet Jesus Christ, and no torture could ever separate me from
his love.
Whatever he said, I am the light of the world, whoever follows me will not walk in darkness,
but will have the light of life.
As for your gods, who made neither heaven nor earth, they shall perish from the earth, and
from under the heavens.
The king's anger was inflamed, and he gave the order to his soldiers to place a red hot
helmet on the saint's head.
Covered in dew, like the three young men in the furnace, Saint Paraskevi felt no suffering.
Her breasts were cut off, and she was thrown into prison with a heavy stone on top of her
wounded chest, but was healed by an angel who appeared in a great earthquake.
Seeing the miracle, 70 of the garrisons' soldiers were converted to Christ.
At the tyrant's order, they were immediately executed, and Paraskevi was brought before
him again.
When she reiterated her ardent confession of faith, the saint was plunged into a bronze
cauldron, filled with molten lead.
Yet here too, her body, having received through virginity and askecies, the first fruits of
future incorruptibility, remained untouched.
Thinking that the mixture was not at boiling point, the tyrant went up to it, and was blinded
by the heat of the furnace, recognizing his fault, through the painful consequences he
began to cry, have pity on me, oh servant of the true God!
Give me back my sight, and I shall believe in the God whom you proclaim.
Through the saint's prayers he received not only his sight, but also the light of faith,
and at his request was baptized in the name of the Holy Trinity, along with all his entourage.
Once free, saint Paraskevi left the region to continue her mission, finding herself in
a town governed by a certain esculapios.
She was proclaiming Christ when she was arrested and brought before the tribunal.
When esculapios asked her to say who she was, the saint made the sign of the cross, and
declared that she was a servant of the God who created heaven and earth, who had offered
himself on the cross for our salvation, and who would return in glory to judge the living
and the dead.
The tyrant had her beaten with rods, but the saint continued to glorify God.
Her gaze turned towards heaven, and when esculapios halted the torturers to ask if she would sacrifice,
she spat on him with disdain in her eyes.
Beside himself with rage, he told the soldiers to flay her to the bone.
Yet after a night spent in the dungeon, the soldiers found her once again unharmed.
In Paraskevi asked to go to the temple of Apollo, all the pagans rejoiced, thinking she would
at last agree to offer sacrifice.
Once there, after long prayer, she made the sign of the cross, and all the idols tumbled
down, making a great noise, and the people cried out, great is the God of the Christians.
The priests who were responsible for the idols were outraged, and furiously demanded that
she be put to death.
She was thrown into a pit, but by her prayer she put to death the dragon and reptiles that
were there, realizing that all his attempts had remained totally fruitless, esculapios sent
the saint to another region, governed by the cruel tarassios.
While she was healing all the sick who came to her through the invocation of the name of Christ,
the king summoned her to appear before him, accused her of practicing magic, and had her
thrown into a stinking pit full of venomous wild beasts.
Through the sign of the cross, this foul hole became like a fragrant spring meadow, and
the saint protected by an angel remained untouched by all the other tortures they inflicted
upon her.
Unable to contain his rage, the king ordered that the servant of God be beheaded.
According to her knees, Paraskevi prayed with tears, confiding her courageous soul to
Christ her spouse, and asking him to grant the forgiveness of sins to all who would honor
her memory.
When her head fell under the sword, a heavenly voice was heard, welcoming the saint into
the kingdom of heaven, a kingdom she had announced by her proclamation and the miracles that
had accompanied her.
From that time forth, fragments of her relics scattered in various churches have not ceased
to accomplish numerous healings.
In particular, those concerned with diseases of the eye.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.